as promised joining me here on the rich
eisen show for the first time
on zoom and for the first time as a
philadelphia 76ers head coach friend of
the program doc rivers how are you doc
i am doing terrific sorry about the
light background in the back you know
that's uh
motion detectors i guess but i'm doing
absolutely phenomenal
um you know we're trying to have an nba
season
through cobit uh and we're finding out
that
it's difficult you know i think we knew
that though
so that's one why i guess that's what i
want to begin with you because you know
there was a game recently where it was
the philadelphia seven sixers it felt
like to me
doc yeah yeah that's i should have used
that
that's pretty good yeah you know
philadelphia seven sixers i mean
because it obviously you you were in the
bubble um
with the clippers and now going through
this outside of a bubble
are there any concerns from you that
this is gonna be
uh paused at any point in time because i
know the nfl season
we went through a period where i felt
that maybe but then it didn't
the same thing with baseball didn't but
uh it did feel at that point
as well but what do you think right now
yeah well i'm hoping not let me put it
that way i think we're at that point
right now where there's concern rich
that
that we're going to have the pulse i
don't want to have a pause i don't think
a pause would be
good for us if you know what i mean so
um
but it also is very difficult we played
a game with eight players
dress only seven available uh the other
night and to give away a game
is very difficult uh it's what you don't
want to do you know
like football and baseball there's so
many players on a roster
no basketball there's 15 players and
there's probably only eight or nine that
have been played
per team and so if you have two or three
guys out
it makes a major difference so obviously
you know seth curry uh
got it on your team and i mean what do
you do with your protocol i mean what
how do you tell your players when
something
is obviously going around to the point
where
it feels like half the country has it
but what do you tell your players i mean
it's it's immediate it's immediate i
think the nba does a great job
you know seth was out in that game
and then immediately like we found out i
think it was halftime right
uh of the game and uh they came and
grabbed them
they they isolate them immediately and
then they do all the contract tracing
which is amazing uh how well that the
nba at least does that
and unfortunately with contract tracing
with the basketball team
it's pretty close contact with a lot of
guys i think whether we lose
five guys just because they sit at a
dinner table with them
uh that morning and even though the
chairs showed that their
space uh we deemed they still were too
close
so uh they're all out and they you know
it was frustrating
rich i would say it was very frustrating
for those guys
because it's 15 day or five days right
and they're healthy
but they can't play uh because they have
to wait till the testing results come
back
i thought that was you know i hadn't
seen that yet this first time it
happened to us
i thought that was the biggest thing is
with the other guys being frustrated
that they're healthy and can't play
doc rivers here uh on the rich eisen
show so okay
cover it aside what how do you like your
team right now doc
it seems like embiid is playing out of
his skull right now and you do have a
bunch of
uh injured players but some youngsters
that um daryl mori
uh got you in the draft it seems like
people are
beginning to gel despite uh the stop and
start
with covet and not what do you got for
me on that i love our team
uh you know and uh i think we're seven
and oh
rich when we're all healthy so uh
we just haven't had a lot of health of
late uh or i don't even know what you
call it it's not health
we just haven't had player availability
of late
um you know we still are a new team
it would be nice especially now we can
just get together and practice and be
together
we just can't but i like the makings of
the markings of this basketball team
what is embiid like oh he's great first
of all he's
i i love conversations with him because
he's explaining
you've heard it that he's just a very
bright guy
and so you know i like our exchanges i
like our discussions because it's more
than
just basketball uh that we're talking
about actually i have a lot of guys
there's a
really bright team in that way uh going
through the whole thing right now
not just covet but a lot of the social
justice issues and just social issues
in general it's been really good um
having conversations with these guys um
and you know we also have a team full of
a couple like three or four rookies that
we're teaching them along the way
and it's good for them to see that it's
more than just basketball
that is discussed in pro sports doc
rivers here
on the rich eisen show um you know we're
all thrust in many times in our jobs
where you don't know
um that you're about to be thrust into a
certain role
you know obviously you experienced that
with the clippers with donald sterling
back in los angeles and then during the
bubble
uh when social justice was
uh quite um on the forefront of
everybody's minds in the country but
certainly in the nba and the nba players
you had a soliloquy in a post-game press
conference about america
about um people of color in america
and it turned into a lincoln project
advertisement millions of people saw it
did you ever think you would be in a
position of being
a social justice face front
individual in the nba doc no nor do i
care to be uh but
you know listen i i come from chicago
and i come from a family
that has always been involved in what's
right is right you know
uh it's funny we do call it social
justice or injustice
uh my parents used to say what's right
is right you know equality
for all and you know my dad always said
something rich that i think more people
should hear just because one group of
people want equality and in this case
there's many groups
it's not just blacks uh it's it's a lot
of people
that that want it um you know just
because they want equality that means
they're taking away your equality you
know what they're saying is they want
the same thing
they want equal rights and equal rights
should not
be a political statement it should be
something that
we all morally want for each other
uh but we we still all need to listen to
each other
as well and i think as a country we have
to do a better job of that
where do you think everything is in
terms of the nba as you know the nba
said that they were going to get
involved and there was
um you know uh there was a conversation
in the bubble about not playing
uh the nba and and the owners got
together and said that
we want to map out a plan where do you
think that plan sits right now
i think that plan is great i mean we
already have done things getting arenas
uh as voting venues for for the
elections
we're terrific uh we have a social
justice council now uh
that i'm on uh that is gonna do good
work
because it's not just us we're hiring
outside people
to lead us uh to to target things that
we need to
uh be aware of and so what i loved about
the bubble number one
was that it was about the young people
you know obviously i said what i said
and i got a lot of the rub
uh but what people didn't see was all
the young people being involved
uh and being emotional and trying to
figure out where to go with all this
stuff
uh and they targeted several areas and
they're doing it
um i love where not just the nba
is at with young people i love the young
people right now in america
have decided that they do have a say and
they're going to get involved in the
voting process they've been involved in
politics because let's just be honest
politics
are involved in you every single day
so when you hear people say i don't want
to get involved i'm thinking
okay but it's involved in you so you
might as well get involved
doc rivers here uh on the rich eisen
show okay
um so why why the sixers doc
what what attracted you to wind up in
philadelphia when
you you you always understand the
conversations that people have
about embiid and simmons not being able
to really
be a cohesive unit and all the politics
to use the phrase that might have been
involved
uh within that locker room why why throw
your hat in that ring
i saw their ability and i saw that they
were young
you know both very young guys and you
know it's
funny the narrative not just here but in
a lot of places
you know when i was thinking about
taking a job i was getting calls
you know uh they haven't won anything
and i said but you
keep forgetting to say yet you know it's
the yet part
that to me uh when you're in the mid-20s
yet is a big word you haven't done a lot
of things yet
you know and so for me that's why i
looked at this group
because there's a group of two young
superstars that are
young they have a lot of basketball left
in them and i wanted to play a part in
that
um i also like the city like i i love
a town that is nuts about sports you
know
people forget i was in boston for a long
time and
you can't get better than boston as far
as that and feeling very similar when
you're in a grocery store
in boston in a grocery store in philly
there's a great chance an 80 year old
lady
is going to tell you you need to play
and beat more
you know they're going to give you their
opinion i love that i think that's
when you have a city that is invested in
sports uh
like my chicago bears and the team of
chicago
well i'm going to get to that in one
second don't you worry but i i love the
fact that you i love the fact
you know you're i can i could say this
you're one of my favorite people and so
is daryl mori
um i i just love that he you know
whenever he's been on my show he just
spits the truth and on occasion he knows
where that line is between
getting fined by adam silver or not and
it's just fun just listening to pick his
mind we'll talk about smart people as
well
how do you and he mesh how do you think
you and he
work together that philadelphia sixers
fans
might want to know about just oh very
well first of all we had a relationship
you know we were in boston together i
told them now let's not do the same
thing because we're in boston doing the
losing years
in boston i said let's be in philly
together during the winning years now
um so that helped uh it also helped the
moment i was fired from the clippers my
first call
literally to me was daryl morley he
calls right away and wants
me to come to houston and i told him no
that's not going to happen
uh i jokingly said you know hey why
don't you come to philly with me
uh and i was literally joking with him
because i told him that's probably where
i would be going
uh and then you know listen it worked
out but the relationship with him and
elton and me
uh we literally talk every day we're
open book
i love his brain i just love his brain i
think he's one of the smarter men
uh in team sports and i and i really
believe that
he has the ability to see trades and see
the cap
uh and see maneuvers not just for now
but for later
that's not me i can't do that right but
what he does well
what we do well is we listen to each
other you know
daryl has had several trades so far
that's no
don't want to do that and he moves on
you know and so
that's the type of relationship you have
to have when you have coaching
management i think it works that way
did one of them in volvo now former
houston rocket
dog no no no that was obviously a big
thing obviously
uh and as i said after that
i'm glad where we're at right now
sometimes
the best trades you do is the ones you
don't do and i'm hoping that's the case
so uh before i let you go uh you want
i'll give you the floor
what do you think the bears should do
with trubisky doc
i think they should keep them i'm a
keeper i know i'm not the minority
in that i i think i i know it i think
they should keep him he's a good player
uh he's solid he got better this year um
you know i love first of all and i'm
gonna say this
and that because i'm a darn coach all
right i'm a bears fan
i love to kept maggie i'm a big maggie
fan
i'm bullish on him as well uh i love our
defense
i think we're closer than people think
you know that that's not what let's say
an
80-year-old woman in a supermarket in
chicago is telling matt
trust it's not what my brother is saying
right now
[Laughter]
this is what i say do you do you reach
out to naggy do you coach
yeah yeah we text back and forth all the
time
uh you know we have a great relationship
he uh brought me in doing kobe to talk
to the team
uh and i did i also you know talked to a
couple other teams my
as i say i always talk to my brother
philip rivers no matter where he's at
so you know i love football i you know
that man i
love football i love the workings of it
it's so much more complicated in some
ways
than basketball but the execution of
plays and what just
makes me love that sport yeah the neck
up stuff is really intense
and obviously people have to do the neck
up stuff
while looking across the line of
scrimmage know that there's 11 grown-ass
men that are coming to try and
take them out so uh you want to handicap
the
the field here nfc afc championship game
you got man that's
it's two tough calls i um you know
i got kc uh if if mahomes plays
right i think they might be trending in
that direction but you never know yeah
and then you know where i'm going with
this
i got tom brady all right
and aaron rodgers is the mvp but he's a
packer
i'm from chicago and i just can't do it
i can't i just can't so i'm going with
tom brady as my savior
right have you ever teeded up with tom
you ever played with him i have not i've
been at the club with him you know at
bel air
but i've yet to play with him yeah right
i mean because
yeah i guess the only guy you could
compare him to is would be jordan
in the fact that every slide is personal
don't look at him the wrong way because
you could might
you might get you might get the the
horns you know what i'm saying i love
his leadership
i i you know and you know i don't know
what it is about guys like
him but they have the ability to lead no
matter where they're at
and people don't realize great leaders
have to get people to follow
uh and when you're in pro sports to get
a whole locker room to follow you with
all those egos
means you're magical uh and and actually
you know aaron is pretty good at it as
well okay that's my one packer
compliment
all right that's it that's it for me uh
but brady is the best leader uh not only
as a quarterback but best leader in
football
in a very long time all right doc thanks
for the time have a
of a great uh be healthy my god all
right hope to see your team uh
as one and seeing them uh back to full
strength real soon thanks for the time
thanks nice seeing you right back at you
that's doc rivers right here on the rich
eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here